هل تذكر المره الاولى التي اطلت بها على
قناه العربيه ومباشره وماذا كان الموضوع
في الواقع كانت هناك تحضيرات في باريس
للتظاهره ضخمه تنديدا بما كان يحضر له من
اجتياح للعراق تتذكر طالب وانت كنت على
النشرات حينها التي تحدثت عن هذه
التحضيرات الاجتياح الجوي اذا جاز التعبير
بدا في التاسع عشر من اذار مارس والبري في
العشرين منه قبل ذلك بايام تظاهر فارسيه
ضخمه طلب مني ان احضر تقريرا تجريبيا
بايلوت لا يبث فحضرت هذا البايلوت ولكن
المشرفين على
غرفه الاخبار ان يبث هذا التقرير عن
التظاهر الضخمه احتجاجا على ما يحضر له من
اجتياح للعراق وبث في نشره مسائيه كنت انت
تقدمها كان هذا اول عمل لي كنت اخشى من
وجود ثغرات في التقرير المصور وانا القادم
كما ذكرت من العمل
الاذاعي كما ذكرت طالب في سؤالك انا قادم
من عمل اذاعي في اذاعه الشرق [__] مر
لسنوات طويله ولكن التقرير المصور في
العربيه ولم يكن مجرد تقرير تجريبي